you go os devolveremos a casa es el
mensaje del presidente de eeuu joe biden
a los estadounidenses y colaboradores
afganos que siguen atrapados en
afganistán decenas de miles de personas
deben ser evacuadas antes del 31 de
agosto fecha marcada para la retirada de
tropas
y esta es una de las evacuaciones aéreas
más grandes y difíciles de la historia y
el único país del mundo capaz de
proyectar tanto poder en el otro extremo
del mundo con este grado de precisión es
eeuu de américa
evacuaciones pero también mucha espera
así estuvo durante todo el viernes el
aeropuerto de kabul
la desesperación aumenta después del
informe de la onu que advertía de la
búsqueda del talibán de ciudadanos que
hayan colaborado con fuerzas extranjeras
mientras la premio nobel de la paz
afgana malalai usar se mostró
preocupación por el futuro de las
mujeres de afganistán
tenemos miedo de que nos vuelvan a
privar de nuestros derechos estoy
preocupada por mis hermanas afganas y
espero que no se les arrebate su
libertad la rutina regresa a la ciudad
de edad con la tradicional oración del
viernes y el talibán muestra dos caras y
una más abierta con milicianos
haciéndose autorretratos en lugares
turísticos pero también la del terror
como estos combatientes armados en la
ciudad de qalat rusia y china están
mostrando una apertura más diplomática
al talibán
no podemos dejar de lado la realidad son
autoridades de facto no hay alternativa
a los talibanes
ante estos miles de afganos tratan de
cruzar la frontera con pakistán serían
10.000 personas según la ong italiana
emergency